To get t by itself you first want to divide both sides of the equation by 1000.
On the left-hand side that leaves us with 1.25 and simplifying what we have in
the parenthesis here. We have 1.03 to the t on the right-hand side. Now all we
have over here term of an exponent. So we just need to take some sort of log of
both sides to get t down out of the exponent, and by itself. Now as we've seen
before the log we need to use should have the same base as this base right
here, 1.03. So, interestingly enough, using log of base 1.03 for both sides.
Well, that's certainly different from anything we've seen, but it works in the
same way as a log with the base of any other number. On the right-hand side
here, we just get t. And on the left-hand side we have this log expression that
we would of course like to evaluate. Now I usually prefer having t on the
left-hand side, so I'm just going to switch it over there now. That just makes
things easier for me to see. Now since we don't have a log based 1.03 button on
the calculator, we're going to need to use change of base. How about this time
we use log of base 10. That means we're going to have, log base 10 of 1.25
divided by log base 10 of 1.03. Let's plug it in and see what that equals. So
here's our famous calculator. Log of 1.25 divided by log of 1.03. What does
that equal? Let's find out. 7.54914 and so on. Remember though, since Grant's
interest gets compounded only once a year, we need to round this up to 8, the
next highest integer. So, that is our answer. After 8, years Grant will have
over $1250 in the account.